про сюжет котеджний пос перед тисячі
правильних у центрально-європейського
університету будапешті see you портос то
є про те нового закону ще до вищого
святим через мету документ за грізну
закрити aucune вся американська угорська
вище за заснований після падіння
комунізму у 90 пішому роті
за сном знайомий університету я
американський мільярдер звільнить за схоже
ним Джордж Сорос
відомі своїми ліберальними підлогу поруч і
назва жінка тягни філантроп soros по
суті дружинам чином на включаєте праворуч
університету
на право папи римського у ряду прибиральниці
гвинт заклятий ворог
на наших інтересах matter of steve aoki
логіці накладається зрубати інна десантним
наш демократично прибраний у років дівоче
вид імені з віконця іноземних агентів
так їх я Джордж зріс його організації в
гарсі не то менших ринок святі
фейковими н і про те ми вдаватимемося
20-х легальних чоловіків вас то я б
просто стоять і його в пливу циpка гани
свистка для всіх звільніть поважаючи
професор економіки все та you
адам заводський 10 рокер на все в
бостоні all з введенням приводу сюди
спрощені ви кладу ти в центрально
європейському університеті веденому своїм
високому рівно musvid і легше університет
не зможе дали протитечію дтп зі 100 на
велику проблему для кроїлі to die
угорські студентики правду театр та мото
свиту міжнародного ременя не зможе
більше заробити а в будинки в вони поїдуть
на чат з і за кордон і можна ви вже
ніколи не повернутися авторитарний і
ряд прем'єра віктора орбана хоче
сказала the pool одну цю победу
відривання угорської чи марокканської
магістра та доктора наук новий закон
вимагаючи про їхній головний камбуз
університету букві відкритий у США
фінансово ціни реального клінцова цін
упізнані закласти університету поважає
ректор закладу
сивкова самоврядування інституція
нарізним кам'яним демократії та
університети я відтепер знати найстаріших
інституті самоврядування у світлі
найбільшої німецькі університети mode
столітню історію і геть і спраги був
рясними у самоврядування у крим диких
ви нитки а ти сам ці цінності заїки ми
боремося я не затікала ні у
політичному протистоянню з паном
орбаном я не засікав інший у його
ідеології ми недатований мас правої
я засікав вона і вийшов за 6-ти інститутом
і ще б пак
шви джамали поверну-то сюди працює
між університетом і поруч на рази
ведуться переговори про і знає і ви
рішення проблеми
алашан цього петельний будапешт
найбільшою годиною з косою новий закон
набагато